good morning hick it's Tuesday so when I
was a tiny little newborn baby back in
January of 2023 do you know what I said
was my big goal for the year do you know
D let's play the tape sometimes Hank
sometimes you need to take it down a
notch and that's my only goal for 2023
just take it down a notch ah buddy
that's uh that's cute breaking news from
The Real World you do not get to decide
the notch situation welcome to 2023 your
brother is going to get a little bit of
cancer so that's going to take it up a
notch also you're going to be
unexpectedly promoted to reluctant and
temporary CEO of two companies with a
total of 115 employees up a notch Hank's
gonna have to get chemo and radiation
taking it up yet a further Notch also
he's going to continue to come up with
millions of business ideas up a notch
also you're gonna have a somewhat
dramatic confrontation with one of the
world's largest pharmaceutical companies
over the price of a tuberculosis drug or
possibly two of the world's largest
pharmaceutical companies if the other
one doesn't get their act together and
stop price gouging the world's poorest
countries things will not be taken down
a notch if anything the notch is like a
helium balloon that slips out of your
fingers sometime in late February and
you just watch as the notch situation
Rises and Rises now of course the notch
situation will probably descend at some
point but it's not for you to know how
or when or where because you little
buddy are as Robert Penn Warren
memorably put it a bubble on the tide of
Empire now look it can be a helpful
delusion to imagine that we have more
control over Our Fate than we actually
do right like if I felt all the time the
way I feel walking onto an airplane I
have absolutely no say in whether I
survived this journey I wouldn't be able
to function and also I wouldn't be
giving myself any agency when of course
I do have a little bit right like I
might be a bubble on the tide of Empire
but I am nonetheless some small part of
the tide and the choices I make do
matter but the great risk of imagining
that I decide the notch situation is
then extrapolating and imagining that
other people decide their Notch
situation and that can lead to all kinds
of stigma and dehumanization right like
Hank we've both seen comments that are
like Hank got a vaccination so he got
cancer or Hank worked too hard so he got
cancer or Hank has ulcerative colitis so
he got cancer Etc and all those comments
are designed to make the person
commenting feel better like I'm not
gonna get cancer because I don't have
Colitis or I'm not going to get cancer
because I didn't get vaccinated it's not
about Hank it's about them and
furthermore trying to find the cause
when you're not like Hank's Physicians
is obviously not about Hank or his
well-being it's obviously about you know
wanting to feel better yourself wanting
to feel like you're never gonna have to
take it up a notch now I want to
emphasize that for Hank these comments
have been super super rare and almost
everyone has been extraordinarily
supportive but Hank's experience is just
to State the obvious not typical and I
do think that whether you're living with
HIV or cancer or tuberculosis or another
highly stigmatized disease the social
response to the illness is part of what
makes the illness so difficult which
come to think of it was not the original
point of this video the point of the
video was that you don't get to decide
the notch situation but if and when the
opportunity to take it down a notch
emerges Hank I want to take that
opportunity which brings me very
belatedly to the question at the center
of this video since 2007 with a few
notable exceptions our videos have been
required to be under four minutes in
length we started this rule to force us
to be concise and to make appropriate
and intentional use of people's
attention and I I like the four minute
rule like I think it's helped me become
a better writer without the four minute
rule I think the Fault in Our Stars
would have been like a hundred Pages
longer and not nearly as good but it's
often a lot of work to take a video idea
and somehow get it under four minutes
like there really is something to that
old line I would have written you a
shorter letter if only I had more time
anyway since Hank's diagnosis we've
suspended the four minute rule to be
able to make videos with a little more
flexibility and I kind of love it like I
think this video is going to be over
four minutes and to get it under four
minutes I would have had to cut all that
stuff about stigmatization and notches
which I I like on the other hand I
understand that it's an important and
long-standing Rule and one of the
reasons we've been able to make stuff
for so many people for so long so I'm a
little conflicted and basically I'm
gonna trust y'all to decide whether we
should continue doing the four minute
rule via a poll in the doobly-doo let us
know what you think listen you do not
decide the notch level but I will tell
you something from experience feeling
accompanied and unalone as The Notches
go up helps does it help as much as the
notch is coming down no but it helps so
thank you for being here with us really
now more than ever Hank I'll see you on
Friday